in northern pelu has dem pics through
the remains of his home reminders of
happy family times lay ruined and
mangled the tsunami wiped out 50 houses
here
the owners are all gone now has dim is
looking for any scraps that can be
salvaged or sold to help him survive the
tsunami is there anything left when I
ask what's left he's homeless
his street is next to the beach so was
hit by the full force of the waves a
boats been tossed where homes once stood
so this is where your family lived we
meet Zeno who lives next door this
natural disaster hasn't just taken his
home ten of his relatives are dead 70
neighbors drowned he says more bodies
are buried in the ruins Wow but Assad
Catoctin up in China for Assad Qatar
Qatar the problem no dr. Taketa dai
bando
Pomerance indeed Allah bando mana man
Tony owada on Tokita someone targeted
Morita he introduces us to men in his
family who are guarding the wreckage
there may not seem like much to steal
but people are desperate so they're
taking turns keeping watch of the road
we see why people are looting from the
local shop food and water is running low
so they grab what they can eat boo lily
tells me she has a dozen mouths to feed
what the government gives isn't a nut
she says fuel is now a precious
commodity as petrol stations run dry
young boys scoop out what they can from
the tank while adults jostle for hours
to get their share the lucky ones who
can fill their cars join the exodus
fleeing the city terrified by days of
aftershocks they pack what they can and
escape this is now the problem facing
people wanting to get in and out of Pulu
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means crashes
aid can't access those and lead and
those trying to escape I stuck as well
and along the route along slide white
this one may hold the shadow of death
hangs over this city they've run from
rescuers are still searching for
survivors as we watch another body is
pulled out no one has been found alive
here today the death toll is rising one
still hostin awaits for news of her
brother after his motorbike was found in
the field yeah they're filled up at my
anthem Gautama Pope may be fading but
until everyone is found the rescuers
won't give up at a city hotel they
search in the dark three people may
still be alive here and after hundreds
of deaths they're desperately hoping for
a miracle
sh'mon Robbins Sky News blue